this is one of the main streets in  monterosso as well as fatalities the  deluge has caused hundreds of people to  flee their homes in the Tuscany region  as several rivers broke their banks car  struggled along highways near the town  of levanto the emergency services had to  bulldoze their way through roads blocked  by trees following mudslides at Bragg  not oh the damn overflowed the region is  part of a World Heritage Site popular  with tourists many of them are being  evacuated from the area by see locals  said the damage was catastrophic the  rescue effort is being hampered by the  damage done to the region's  infrastructure to Myrtle Sky News